[LAUREL/YANNI CLIP PLAYS]
DANA BOEBINGER: Laurel.
KEVIN SITEK: Yanny.
DANA BOEBINGER:
It just is Laurel.
KEVIN SITEK: I've listened to
this so many different ways
and all I can ever
hear is Yanny.
DANA BOEBINGER: So this is kind
of like the auditory version
of the dress that we
saw a few years ago
on the internet, in that its
a physical stimulus that's
out there and it's
kind of ambiguous,
and depending on how
the brain is choosing
to interpret the
signal, you're going
to perceive it a
totally different way.
So here, we're looking
at a spectrogram
of the auditory
illusion itself--
the Laurel or Yanny word.
And what we're actually
seeing is that, on the x-axis,
in the horizontal
direction, is time.
And then the y-axis
is the frequency.
So it's low at bottom
and high at the top.
And you can see that, while it
sounds like a voice might only
be one pitch, there's
actually a whole bunch
of different frequencies
included in that speech sound.
KEVIN SITEK: There's a
big gap on the lower side.
It's not white.
So there's definitely
some energy there--
some acoustic energy.
And so what could be
happening is that people
who hear Laurel are actually
putting another line
through that space.
Whereas people who
hear Yanny, they're
going to say that whatever is
in between the two really dark
bands is actually just noise.
DANA BOEBINGER:
Yeah, so it all has
to do with what frequencies
your brain is deciding
are important for figuring
out what speech sound it is.
KEVIN SITEK: So this
is what it sounds
like if you cut out
the high frequencies
and only have the
low frequencies.
[LAUREL/YANNI CLIP PLAYS]
I even hear Laurel.
SPEAKER 1: I heard Laurel.
SPEAKER 2: Mm-hmm.
It's Laurel.
DANA BOEBINGER:
Yeah, that's Laurel.
SPEAKER 2: It's Laurel.
KEVIN SITEK: Right.
Definitely.
And if you cut out the
low frequencies and you
only have a high frequencies--
[LAUREL/YANNI CLIP PLAYS]
Was that Yanny?
DANA BOEBINGER: That's Yanny.
KEVIN SITEK: I
think it's probably
good to have some friends
on the Laurel side.
DANA BOEBINGER: That's right.
We all need friends
in Laurel places.
[LAUGHS]